foreign
but I do feel like he's mine and my
original question was just I just don't
know if we should get married is that
true is that not true what do you think
unfortunately I have been emotionally
Unfaithful I've never basically done
anything with anybody like that
[Music]
whoa what is going on this is John with
the Dr John deloney show show about your
mental health your emotional health your
relational Health whatever you got going
on in your life you talk to real people
going through real struggles
whether it's with their their mental
health Diagnostics whether it's with
marriage or relationship issues or
boundary challenges with in-laws and
work workplace issues or if it's trying
to figure out how to parent your kids
and how to better love your neighbors
man we we talk to everybody on the show
about anything if you want to be on this
show
you're struggling with something and you
want some some somebody to sit with you
as you figure out what you're going to
do next give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k
um
hey uh big news guys in the booth
Kelly's not even paying attention
what I'm just playing what I've got big
news we're talking about the storm I've
got big news yeah there's a big storm
tell me what is your news it's so huge
here's the news so this morning
um I was down I was invited to go get a
a tour by the head guitar builder at
Gibson so we were down at the Gibson
Factory this morning
it was so incredible and I had these
dreams as I was leaving
um I'm gonna do it like I am gonna sit
down with the Gibson custom shop and I'm
gonna have them make me like my
personalized dream guitar it's gonna
cost me a jillion like a car
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna save up
and do this
and then my wife called
and we've had this uh last uh started
started yesterday this GFCI plug kept
tripping and tripping and tripping and
tripping and tripping and I unplugged
everything it kept tripping and tripping
and I couldn't believe it but as I
started tracing it back in my house and
I have live in an old house out in the
woods right
um so much of the house was tied into
this one plug so we called the
electrician electric company and it
wasn't just like Billy Bob's electric it
was it's a it's a firm it's a group that
comes out and they're awesome
and when they called my wife they said
hey we've diagnosed the problem you're
going to want to sit down
so needless to say we will not be
getting a John Delaney custom Gibson
guitar because so instead of an electric
guitar we're going to have electricity I
told the guy I told him I was like uh I
need you to tell me how it's this
expensive it's eighteen thousand dollars
to rewire everything everything new new
panels the back stuff is falling off
it's everything it's got to be run from
the pole 18 Grand and I asked the dude I
said hey I'm gonna have to explain to my
kids y'all are getting refrigeration and
electricity for Christmas and so help me
sell this and uh anyway it's gonna be
it's gonna be beautiful and it's all
done but holy smokes that put put some
sadness in my Gibson wanting heart but
alas it's all we have emergency funds
right such it is
ah all right Mary it's up to you to make
everything all right I'm gonna
go out to Toronto Canada and see if you
can help me Mary help me
I don't think I can
I'm really happy to talk to you though
awesome awesome hey so what's going on
how can I help
it's kind of a two-part question
um how do I explain to my kids about my
financial situation or my lack of money
Financial where I used to be able to say
do things that they wanted to and now I
can't and how do I teach them the value
of money when on the other side their
father spends and my ex-husband spends
money like crazy
um yeah so what happened y'all you got
divorced
yeah it was a very bad divorce yeah and
when you found out I had more I had more
custody when he found out that he would
have to pay child support he wanted 50
50 custody just so he wouldn't have to
pay child support and like everything he
does he tries to make sure that he gives
me the least money possible
um so that's like single mom with three
boys so and I am I'm on my farm and it's
not like I have a certain income from
that and it's very busy to say get a
second job
um we're fine but you know I can't do
things like I used to and you know they
always question why and like Dad has
money well how come and Dad spends money
on fun stuff and I have to spend you
know like my extra money on their Sports
and tutoring and not fun stuff yeah I
hate that for you I'm sorry
thanks
um
like we can talk about the money part
but
um and I won't even dig into the other
stuff because that's not why you called
but
I know that hurts
like all of it
and if you yeah yeah it is and if you
look at the data
even in 50 50 custody splits men's net
worth goes up over time
while Single Mom's net worth goes down
even if it's even if the money's split
and there's several different theories
as to why that happens but
and it may be because Dad gets to buy
fun stuff whenever he wants but mom has
to actually pay for things that the kids
are doing and they actually need and
those things are expensive and they add
up but all I have to say is this I'm
sorry
how old are these boys
um
8 10 and 12. okay that's perfect so
they're old enough to begin to have some
um
more challenging conversations so here's
a couple of big picture things we're not
gonna do okay
number one we are not gonna get into a
comparison game with Dad it's a Fool's
errand there's a reason y'all got
divorced okay yeah
um you don't want to get into that game
so you're going to have to do the work
on your end
that when they come home and say guess
what Dad bought us guess what Dad got
guess what dad took us that you are able
to Exhale and on behalf of your boys
say I'm glad my boys got to have a good
time
like I'm glad that they were able to
have this experience because they
clearly had a great time
not gonna you have to practice that
otherwise you're going to be so filled
with bitterness you know what I mean
because it's not about him anymore he is
out of your life
and that's part of the hard part like
there's so much resentment for him as
well that I don't want to have and I
don't want to put that kind of burden on
my boys either I know and the money
question well you you just brought it up
so I'm gonna go there I this is a money
question but this is like a 30 second
money question
this is a you sound as a wife who's an
ex-wife who's hurt very badly is that
true
yeah yeah
and
I'm gonna tell you please don't let that
resentment and bitterness spill over
into your soul one more second and I
know it's easy for me to say
um
but it's going to poison you and your ex
is just going to move on down the road
doing whatever stupid stuff he does
and so your resentment and your
bitterness are simply going to serve to
keep your
um tree from growing you're just gonna
poison your own Roots it's not going to
affect him at all if the amount of
bitterness and resentment you held like
hurt him
you could probably convince me that
that's a good idea but it's not it's
just gonna hurt me there okay
um so how do you let go of resentment
how do you practice that I don't know
another way other than making uh then
having a daily journaling or daily
Writing Practice
where you slowly begin to and this is
gonna sound crazy Mary and you're gonna
be like I hate that I call this guy
but yeah you consciously write down once
a day if you can do it twice a day
you're awesome but once a day
I wish him the best
I wish that guy the best
even though you don't do you
are you laughing at me
it's just like I I don't know if I could
write that like I know I know I know
I know I know
Mary you need to write down you where is
he nope not wish him the best no
because this this is
um you're poisoning yourself you keep
drinking it
and I want you to pour it out before you
pour it down your own throat
and so we're gonna practice hey Dad got
a new truck and his his new girlfriend
she's incredible she I'm glad he's doing
well
good for him
because what's the alternative hoping it
all fails
because I'm gonna tell you it's already
all failed for him
he's so and I know it's not right so
they know like yeah and I kind of do
like because I want my boys to be okay
so like if he's okay like they're okay
that's right
but here's the other deal
um
his life sucks
and he's so stupid he doesn't even see
it yet
and it's like your friend it's like oh
my gosh I just put 25 000 I got 25 000
in an inheritance and I bought a bunch
of Beanie Babies they're gonna be make
us rich and you're thinking oh no no no
no no what are you doing right it's that
he's so stupid he blew up his whole life
and he's gonna have sons that when
they're 25 and 30 they don't talk to
their dad
but do you think that's gonna happen I
know it's gonna happen
I I worked with those boys those men
and there comes a light bulb one day
when they say why did you leave Mom why
did you leave us and by the way how long
is this divorce how long have you all
been splitting 50 50 custody
yeah two years
has it started waning yet
yeah
what do you mean well like this winter
like I had them more that's right
I can almost guarantee you that over the
next three to five years his time with
them will be less and less because
they're going to start intruding as they
become young men they're gonna start
intruding on his good time
and so you are playing I tell everybody
who is gets Divorced with young kids you
instantly go from I want them to have a
good seventh grade year you do still
want that but we are now looking at a 10
to 15 year window
now I want 22 year old men
to never for a second doubt the
character and integrity and love of
their mother
that's the game we're playing now and
it's not a game this is our life but
this this is the shift
and that shift is going to be here's
ways we we teach our kids about love and
connection
you're going to sit down with them and
show them the budget
show them how much money you make
here's how much money we make and here's
how much bills cost here's how much this
cost here's how much this cost here's
how much this cost and this is what we
have left
and some of this goes to savings some of
this goes to giving away and then after
all of that this is what we have
this is why we can't go to the
trampoline park and go camp go good do
all this crazy stuff all the time
and that's not too much of a burden on
them like no it's it's teaching them
you're not shifting the burden to them
you're just saying Hey I want to teach
you guys how to budget and we're going
to do it fun this is how much money we
make in the house
and you can say when your daddy chose to
leave
the court said he had to continue to pay
for your house because he's your dad and
so this is how much money comes in and
my job this is how much money I make at
my job
and I would tell you
you're gonna have to change your
attitude about work for a season
probably
when somebody says hey you may have to
go get a second job or a different job
and you're thinking I can't deal with
any more change I'm so exhausted I can't
even see straight
and you shut down that conversation
which you are shutting down is
five years from now Mary
with a really incredible job and some
kids that are older and they're
teenagers and y'all are having fun you
know are laughing and you've got car
insurance and they've got a vehicle that
they share that everything starts to
shift and right now you don't see it
because you're still in the middle of it
you still hurt you still hate that guy
so much and that rage and frustration
and resentment consume you you have to
let that stuff go
how does that like as I'm saying that
how does that sound I know it sounded
crazy when I told you to write down
every day I wish him well
I hope things are going well for him
sounds hard I want like I want to let go
of that
it's hard picturing it happening it is
can I tell you what I think it's hard
here's what I keep doing dumb like
hurtful and mean things
like
when he's when he's still hurting me
over and over how did you how does he
hurt you right now
well there's things like say with the
boys like with their like with their
activities their sports like that's
something that's really important to
them and then he'll be like no he'll
he'll fight me on it
and he'll and he'll like refuse to say
like they play hockey and he was
refusing to he would only pay for hockey
if he was financially capable and then
he went out and bought a camper
motorcycle and whatever else okay but
why in the world I know that's
frustrating but why do you let him into
your heart like that
do you like do you realize like through
the boys through my kids though like I
know he's he's not I I think he's not
hurting you I think he's hurting these
kids
like that move tells me the character of
a man he is
and I'm not gonna give that man one
second of my day
he cashed it out
that's a man who cheats on his wife
that's a man who can't admit to
challenges that's a man who chooses I'm
gonna go do this right now over
my kids really want to play hockey and
they're pretty dang good and actually
there's been enough disconnection in
their life this is a way to to bring us
all back on the same page
yeah it's a child it's a coward
and I'm not going to give that guy one
second of my day so if he gets a camper
you can shake your head and then go on
about your day any choice after that to
dwell on it to think on it to dig into
that is a choice for
it's a choice for you to be miserable
I'm not gonna do that
and yes what I'm asking you to do is
borderline impossible I get that
that's why I go back to say you've got
to write this stuff down I wish him well
I hope the father of my kids is healthy
and whole making good choices and I hope
he's happy
but as for me and my house
I'm going to be honest to my kids about
the budget I'm going to be honest with
our kids about hey Mom's getting another
job and so I'm not going to be around as
much or we're going to have a babysitter
or I'm getting a new job so I'm gonna
have to do some night school to get some
training so that I can go do this new
job I'm going to make a little bit more
money but explain it to them and not in
a look what your dad did to us but in a
this is reality now and my promise to
you is this Mary
when they're 18 when they're 16 when
they're 25 they're going to remember
these conversations these monthly budget
meetings with Mom
and they're going to begin to ask where
was my dad
why did Dad leave us
why was Dad doing all buying camper
since what in the world
those days will come that Reckoning will
come but again even if it doesn't you
will know and you will sleep well at
night knowing
I was a person of integrity
joy and peace and patience
all the fruits of the spirit
that's who I am
I'm not going to war with people who
cheat
thank you so much for the call be right
back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
let's go out to St Louis Missouri St
Louis
St Louis how do you say it
St Louis St Louis oh it's not Louisville
no yeah that's in Kentucky Louisville
I already got to St Louis Missouri and
talk to Erica cause it's spelled with a
K what's up Erica
uh well
um I'm kind of conflicted
um I guess I'll start with a question
first so my question is
foreign
do I have a right to feel jealous of my
husband's relationship with his sister
that's a good question hey I I I hear
this one more than people would expect
um okay good and I'll be honest it's 50
50. sometimes when I hear it out
I get really frustrated that the
person's even asking this question
because it's about jealousy about my
husband's mine I don't want him to have
inside jokes and laughter with other
people just me there's that and then the
other half of them is husband's a little
bit insane
and
almost relies on sister like uh like a
mother figure a maternal figure and wife
gets left out so tell me tell me what's
going on in your world
well I feel awkward and a little upset
of even having to ask those questions
because I love my sister-in-law very
much we actually have a really tight
relationship and she's an angel like
she's beautiful she's intelligent she's
accomplished she's friendly she's just
amazing why don't you like her
well I love her that's the that's why
I'm conflicted with feeling jealous of
the relationship between her and my
husband
um so I'll start my husband is one of
ten kids
they were raised in a really strict
um home and a really strict
um religious uptrend
so my husband is the second oldest and
uh the oldest brother didn't necessarily
take on his role very well he was just
not really into the whole family thing
so didn't treat the other brothers and
sisters well so my husband took on the
role of the older brother hero as in
like he included all the kids in their
games and
um invited them to do stuff with them so
they all look up to him a lot
um rightly so he's an amazing person but
Helm and his sister which is the next
oldest so it goes to Boulder brother
Hellman then his sister
um have always had a very very tight
relationship they've always been just
the best of friends they grew up they
established a business together and
worked on that for several years
um and then they also
um just call each other daily you know
like they have a very tight Bond
um the reason why I started to get a
little jealous
was because I feel like he gives her the
attention and admiration that I wish she
would sometimes display to me but
instead it all goes to her and I just
feel like I'm kind of left out of our
relationship because it's more so
everything goes towards that one versus
ours
have you have you ever told him I wished
one day
I wish one day you'll look at me like I
see you look at your sister
she's like she's
heard that you would even think that or
um have those thoughts and I'm like yeah
you're right it is like I feel so weird
even talking about this because he's the
other woman but she's not the other
woman
you know it's not like that kind of
relationship
yeah so but but but that instantly goes
to a sexualization of a relationship
yeah
um and I don't think that's I mean I'm
trusting you that's not the case here no
no no so I don't think it's
in his mind maybe
he goes right to a sexual relationship
and he's like no no there's no feel I
don't have feelings for her what's the
matter with you right but it's not about
that for you it sounds like it's about
admiration and attention
and connectivity and just being really
proud I would tell you in many ways in a
family of 10
um he's gonna have played some sort of
paternal role in her life
and almost in a kind of a weird sideways
way like she's his oldest daughter
right and there's gonna be that
pride in that
I
I don't know and you've got that trauma
Bond you've got that strict religious
upbringing that 10 kids in the house all
the chaos that comes with that there's
just going to be some connectivities how
long have y'all been married
uh we have been married now for five
years okay and that's kind of another
thing I'll give you a couple more side
notes as to why I'm starting to kind of
fill the jealous Tendencies
um we recently put up a physical
calendar in our kitchen because we have
three under three so life is kind of
Chaos
yes and so
um we put up a physical calendar to keep
track of just everyday life and get
excited about events that we write down
on there because we have to look forward
to like oh this is family vacation etc
etc so for the month of June it is
really busy for us um we hung up a blank
calendar and I noticed he had wrote a
few things on there uh he wrote when we
started our garden out back and then he
only wrote one other thing which is his
sister's birthday
now in the month of June is our wedding
anniversary and our oldest child's
birthday amongst other family members
birthdays and events so he only wrote
those two things down and I don't know
why but it bothered me so badly that
that's what he remembered to put for the
month of June instead of
our wedding anniversary or our
daughter's date
or could it have could it have been oh
it's okay could it have been and again
I'm just playing devil's advocate here
could it have been that he thought y'all
would think that one through
like as you all put dates on or that you
might put dates on and he wanted to make
sure hey there's two I don't want to
forget like they were just his
um yeah he said that uh it was something
he wanted us all to sit down together as
a family and get excited about him write
together and I was like okay you know I
I can understand that
um but then like on Facebook which he
doesn't have to glorify me in any way
um I'm actually used since I'm not doing
that because he's not typically that
kind of person but he um he put so many
Facebook posts glorifying his sister
about how he couldn't have asked for a
better partner to have a business voice
that he's so proud of her
accomplishments she's intelligent she's
beautiful she's trustworthy and I
haven't got one single thing through the
last several years
and uh then on Mother's Day
um I'm kind of in charge in our house of
taking care of holidays so like for
other people like his mom my mom other
moms and family I'll get things for them
recognize them plan things out for that
holiday and then you know I'll leave it
in his hands to do that for me and our
family
so for Mother's Day
we went to his mom's house and ate
dinner with my mom and different things
of that nature well he never wished me
really a Happy Mother's day and didn't
we didn't do anything for me for
Mother's Day
um again we probably got really caught
up in everyone else but at the end of
the day we were in the car coming home
and he was texting different moms that
he knew happy Mother's Day I appreciate
you I love you thank you for the example
you've set in our lives in our company
Etc and then he found a way to
incorporate his sister into it but she's
not a mom
so in my mind I'm like how did you find
a way to incorporate your sister that's
not even a mom but you haven't wished me
a happy Mother's Day or said anything
heartfelt towards me
so that just really hurt my feelings and
I guess dug it a little bit deeper
okay
so that that would that was not cool
at all
not cool at all
um he blew that one and if he was on the
phone with me I would tell him dude you
blew that one you absolutely blew that
one uh Mother's Day I think's one of
those hard
days that is not really wise to share
that with a bunch of other people or
maybe after you all do something special
but
um right
yeah so here's kind of the path forward
y'all been married five years
you have three kids under three
which means your marriage is zero
percent zero like it was when y'all
first started
yes
and my guess is your husband does not
know what he's doing
but he does know how to how to run a
business and he does know how to cheer
his sister on
yes he doesn't know how to please a
woman who is outside of his that weird
little construct that he grew up in
he doesn't know how to raise three
little baby kids
Because by the time he had three little
littles and he was old enough one of the
other 45 kids in his family was taking
care of him right right
and it's very common in relationships
especially with men is when they don't
feel good at one thing they just lean
into the other stuff and they just go
Full Tilt
yeah here's where this is it's not an
excuse okay just a context so here's
where this gets hard
you're gonna have to sit down and be
very very honest all at the same time
okay and but it's gonna have to be
twofold
one it's gonna have to be here are some
things that all happened in a row
that I feel I experienced
not that you did okay
I really miss the fact that not one
person told me Happy Mother's Day on
Mother's Day
nobody bought me a flower nobody said
thank you so so much
um
that breaks my heart
I even called this podcaster guy and he
said that was pretty lame
okay
and
maybe you get one of or two of his posts
his Facebook posts and highlight it
and say yeah you said she's beautiful
and she's great and she is all those
things but you've never told me that
right okay so that's step one here's
step two
this is the compassionate approach
there's going to be people who hate what
I'm about to tell you okay
hi
I think it's fair for you to be very
explicit about what you would like and
about what you need
I would like you to call me every day
I would like you to tell me you're
beautiful and sometimes just hold my
hand for no reason
I would love for you to ask me in the
morning how can I love you better today
if you put things about your sister
online that's so amazing I'm so jealous
of how great y'all's relationship is
that is so cool and
it would really make me feel good if you
said nice things about me in public too
someday
okay
and you're basically serving as his
teacher now here's where this is really
heart-wrenching he might say no
okay and he might not do it
he might call you crazy
and if he says oh my gosh you're crazy I
would want you to put your hand up and
stop him and say please don't dismiss
how I feel right now
that hurts my feelings too
okay okay
and what you're doing is you're just
teaching a young kid
who suddenly woke up and was married and
then sneezed and has three kids running
around the place
and a small business with a sister it
teaches him
here's what I need to feel safe here's
what I need to feel loved
and then you can turn it around on him
what do you need how can I better love
you
okay okay
this is going to be a risk because it
may not come true and what I'm telling
you is you're going to wish it happened
sooner rather than later
you're going to wish you had this
conversation now because if you find out
if he's like nah I'd rather hang out my
sister than my wife and three kids
that's something you want to know now
so you don't waste two decades with
somebody who's an absolute loser but I
don't think that's the case
um
I had a strange
I used to always buy flowers for
girlfriends always always I was like
wasn't my thing I liked buying flowers I
liked people feeling good an older
sister and saw people treat her really
well Saul people treat her in ways that
made me uncomfortable I always
wanted somebody to leave my presence
feeling good about themselves
and
one day I was talking to my wife when we
were dating about flowers and she made
some offhanded comment like this flowers
but it turns out 10 years later when I
never bought flowers
that I had misinterpreted what she said
at all and then one day she's like how
come you never have ever bought me
flowers
and I was like Oh I thought you didn't
want them and she's like no
I would love to get flowers
and it was this and again this is
something very small but
she taught me
very explicitly here is what I need
here's what I would like
and man I love doing things that make my
wife happy and bring her Joy so there is
a moment for explicit and as a culture
we expect our husbands and our wives and
our girlfriends and our boyfriends to
read our minds and just know things
and man that's cool in the movies it's
just not how it works in real life
it's just not how it works so take a
risk
be explicit about how you feel how you
feel
and then be explicit about here's what I
want and here's what I need
to give him an opportunity to step up
I think it's okay to be jealous in the
oh my gosh I'm so jealous that they have
such a tight relationship but I also
think this is for everybody out there
your husband being really amazing to his
sister or you see your
life being really amazing to her brother
be really grateful that you married
somebody a character
and don't be afraid to speak up and let
them know how they can love you too
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com deloney today to
get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back and we've got a
fun one coming up all right let's go out
to Aubry in San Diego Aubry what's
happening
hey yo how are you I'm good you're there
yes can you hear me okay yes and so my
understanding is you sent in a note and
then you called back and asked hey the
note was about your fiance and you
called back and said hey could my fiance
be on two is that still good
yes
it's gonna be awesome all right I'm
gonna bring on fiancee Kyle in San Diego
Kyle are you there
hey what's up John how are you what's up
Kyle and Aubry all right so here's how
um I'll play referee here I don't fully
know what's happening but
um Aubry you give me the rundown of why
you originally called in
and then we can go from there
okay yeah so we've been um we're engaged
and we've been together for five years
five years what are you what's taking
you so long Kyle
foreign
yes you should be God Almighty okay
Aubrey go for it
[Music]
it's all right you're good take a breath
take a breath
it's kind of the thing is I don't really
feel like I'm his one but I do feel like
he's mine and
my original question was just I just
don't know if we should get married
okay tell me about it
when you say when you say you feel like
um he's your one but you're not his are
there other women in the picture
there has been and there's only been one
major
Downfall with that like you know
sometimes mostly in the past has just
been kind of lingering and he didn't
really act on it but there was just one
major incident but that was in the past
that was okay we got over that but now
like it's still kind of like
um I happen like the lingering is still
happening it just it sucks right now
because we're engaged we're getting
older and we're getting closer to being
married and so I'm just scared of being
in a marriage where you know that's
going to continue to happen because it's
happened quite often in our past when
you say when you say lingering what do
you mean like y'all are out at a
restaurant you just stares somebody up
and down or he's got people that he
talks to or there's people on his social
media that he's always check on like
what what is the what do you mean
lingering
yeah like he's like flirted you know
like flirt like want to make other girls
feel good or want to get attention from
other girls okay
Kyle what say you man
what was that John what what's like when
you hear that and you hear your fiance
of five years
like weeping
um
and she says man I love this guy he's my
one but I don't know if I can marry him
because he's always messaging other
women and talking to other women and
trying to get attention from other women
um
how does that how does that sit with you
is that true is that not true what do
you think
I mean it's unfortunately I have been
you know
emotionally Unfaithful I've never
physically done anything with anybody
like that but you know I've sent
messages and and yeah I mean uh at one
point I did go on a date
um you know that was maybe a year and a
half ago we were going through some
trouble and then I I did go on a date
and nothing happened again but it just
it did hurt her a lot and it hurt me too
and I mean we've been together for five
years and we've been engaged for one uh
well the beginning of this year and
we're set to get married in December
to the end of this year and um I mean I
I hate that I had hurt and I'm hearing
her say it and you know I've heard it
before
um
and I on my end you know I'm not
defending myself I'm not saying I didn't
do anything at the same time you know in
this relationship I've I've asked of my
future wife for certain you know efforts
in our relationship that she also
doesn't take seriously or into
consideration or or
um you know
efforts like what
um
there's uh in the beginning I put a lot
of effort into her family and I know she
did too into mine but I really put a lot
of effort into getting her family and uh
you know all of us good there's just a
little bit of distance there so
you know I I have a close relationship
with my family and it's it's always like
let's check up on each other and and you
know there's a big connection with them
and sometimes I just don't feel that
from Aubry on me and so it just
that lack of um
of effort from that side especially
because my families you know they're
important to me sometimes I feel like it
gets in the way physically I feel like
sometimes there's just no uh romance and
intimacy I mean we haven't been intimate
in a while and every time we try
you know
the past that I've done to like see I'm
sorry sorry it's on to Aubrey is um
you know it gets in the way and and she
rejects me her body just we can't get
very far because you know the past or or
more recently it was you know which is
weren't in a good place the last time we
kind of tried and and yeah I mean I feel
rejected as a man I'm like hey you know
I want to be intimate with you I want I
want to we've been together for a very
long time and you know at the same time
though I also want to do things right
and I know we had to get married
and you know I I I was making my effort
I'm making my effort trying to make
things work sometimes I really feel like
we disagree on a lot
and I mean that's kind of where I'm at
right now I'm just feeling a little
overwhelmed a little confused I mean
this is a commitment for a lifetime one
thing we talk about all the time is hey
it's marriage it is once and for all and
I know that that's why I I don't want to
be a hypocrite to her she calls me you
know a hypocrite which I have been but I
definitely don't want to be a hypocrite
you know we're engaged and we were
boyfriend and girlfriend
but sure sure surely I won't bring that
into a marriage I am 100 promise you you
will
the hardest thing about getting a new
car or getting a new wife or getting a
new house or getting a new job
is that you go with you
and it like
do I have your permission to kind of
just be blunt be straight up is that
cool
no absolutely like we're on the same
team so it's all good I have I I think
there's more to it
I would be willing to bet money
and I don't have a lot but I'd be
willing to bet money that you haven't
told her everything
because here's why
um first of all let me say this when I
say that out loud
true or false there's more to it
true and I did mention more last night I
I confess her that I had resorted to
pornography because there was lack of
intimacy with us and and you know
unfortunately that's part of The
Temptations would creep in and yeah I I
have
um given in to them in that sense
so I I talked about that with her
yesterday
um even
um
foreign
I think there's even more than that
but I'm not there
I'm not in San Diego
here's what I need you to hear both of
you
when you get married it's sickness and
in health
y'all get married it's I'm done being me
and now me is now we it's us
and
Kyle with all due respect man you're
eat
but I'll say it for both of you Aubry
and Kyle you have created a world where
neither of you can win
and both of you have chosen to blame the
other person for the decisions and
choices that you're making
and so Kyle
you didn't have to go to pornography you
didn't have to message girls on the
internet or on Instagram you didn't have
to go meet people
in person
because you had lack of intimacy
you did those things because you chose
to
that's just a decision you made
and
something about you and whatever the
state of your relationship is the safety
that emanates from you
um is not translating to Aubry so much
that the intimacy and closeness that
she's craving her body shuts her down
shuts It Off
says this guy's not safe
there's something else here
and so if I'm if you're marrying my
daughter Kyle I don't want you marrying
her just because you know I want to do I
want to do it right I don't want you
marrying her for that
I want you marrying my daughter because
you can't imagine drawing a full breath
for the next 50 years without her by
your side
and that's not doesn't sound like this
at all
so Aubry when you hear this
or let me ask you this Aubry
can I can I be straight up with you too
yes
it sounds like you're done
you just can't fathom starting over
somewhere again and you still you still
love this guy because you always will
but it sounds like you're done are you
done
absolutely not
no I I want and I Kyle are you done
no be honest bro like for real
are you done and you don't want I know
you love her and I know you don't ever
want to hurt her
but are you finished
I feel as I am
you feel what I didn't understand I feel
I feel as though I am and
I yeah you am what you're you feel like
you're finished I am dying okay
have you told her that
you have okay but I but I've also told
her that maybe I am long and you know
this this phone call it was an effort to
see if if I am
you know absolutely out of my mind
making the wrong decision that you know
I
told him that
okay well I'm gonna applaud you for
being honest I appreciate that
Aubry I've been ball hogging all this
time with Kyle um you've heard this
you've been feeling this this I'm
assuming none of this is new
um and you say absolutely not walk me
through that
I mean I love him and I know that
marriage isn't perfect
and that's I feel like I'm kind of on
the spectrum of optimism and negativity
I'm kind of stupid optimistic and I want
things to work you know I know marriage
is through thick and thin and
so you know we do have to have bad times
and have the good times and all that and
I'm willing to work with him
and we've had this conversation over and
over again and
so let me ask you this already if if
behavior is a language
without using words if behavior is a
language
for the past six months what has Kyle
been telling you
sometimes seem and it's like sometimes
he's in it sometimes he's really in it
but
then when he gets down he gets really
down and right now it's just like
absolutely he wants to be gone he's
making that so obvious that he like he
makes me feel disgusting that
uh he I'm going to be the one that he's
marrying he he obviously doesn't want
that but he doesn't leave like he's
still here and so it does give me
optimism that you know maybe we will
work through it because we always do
so it's hard for me to tell is it over
is it not you're still here
how come you haven't just bailed Kyle
how come you haven't it's like just
called it
that's a good question I mean
um
I don't know I mean I love Lexi I don't
want to hurt her you were writing when
you said that and I sometimes think that
you know
this is all very
it's just Temptation it's just bad
mentality I'm thinking wrong but then
there's the side of me that's like hey
this is a commitment and you guys are
fighting you know quite often and it's
not something yeah
I it's not I don't want to be in a
marriage where we're constantly you know
fighting and it's little bickerings here
and there and we you know
we don't understand each other on some
you know important beliefs I I you know
I've asked her and she says okay I will
try too but then I don't see that effort
and I'm like even last night I asked for
Aubrey the effort you were talking about
where is it and have you brought that
here and then then I'm not talking about
intimacy either I'm talking about like
you don't
hypocritically but I it you know
personally going to church and then
maybe joining your church Community or
maybe it might be healthy for us if we
do because you know this and that but
there's no effort from that or on that
from her side and that does hurt me
because I mean the way I Envision my
future family is a certain way and it's
you know that it's just not translating
or aubry's not doesn't want that and I
ask her if that's fair if you don't want
that but then that's what I want and so
except I think she brought up a good
point brother and I just want to like
like again you and me are just having a
drink eating nachos and I just want to
call it out
um I'm not saying this in the
patriarchal way in the nonsense way from
the Bro literature okay I'm not I'm not
I'm not trying to bro down
but dude you've got to lead the life you
want to lead
and so if you want to be a guy whose
family goes to church every Sunday
whether you're dating somebody or not be
a guy that goes to church every Sunday
if you want to be a guy that doesn't
have a house that there's not a lot of
fights
then every single day of your life ask
the person that you're in love with how
can I love you better today
and I'm gonna do what I can to not to
not have a house with fights and if I'm
with somebody who's
wants to fight or spicy who always
picking stuff then I'm gonna make some
choices to not be in that relationship
but but it sounds like you have this
dream but you want somebody to drag you
along into that dream and if they don't
drag you into that dream you're just
like well bro just things are going to
happen then
which you can do that I'm just gonna beg
you man don't get married
don't do that to yourself don't do that
to Aubry
and Aubry same thing
you want to have laughter and joy and
fun and you want to be married oh that's
awesome
but you've got to do the things in your
life for you that are going to bring you
closer to Joy and optimism and
excitement and fun
I think in a weird way I don't know that
you're optimistic I think you just want
something so bad that you will put
blinders on and pretend that the rest of
the world has just gone blank because
you're gonna make you're you're bound
and determined to make this thing happen
it's like the person who wakes up one
day and it's like I'm losing 50 pounds
period not I'm gonna be healthier and
I'm going to be a good Steward of my
body I'm going to change my life but I'm
losing 50 pounds and they start off
running eight miles a day on a treadmill
and then they start not skipping meals
and then they're six months later
they're taking diet pills and they're
weighed on a rabbit hole because the
goal was just to
um sever this weight off my body it was
never about getting well in whole
and it feels like here in your head I'm
getting married to that guy I'm gonna
Overlook the fact that he keeps telling
me he doesn't want to be with me anymore
I'm gonna Overlook the fact that he is
engaging with other women I'm going to
overlook the fact that every time I'm
around him I pick fights with him and I
drive him crazy I'm gonna Overlook the
fact that my body shuts down every time
we try to get close to one another I'm
gonna override all that crap because I'm
getting married to him
and that's a dangerous goal to have
when you start throwing away all the
other data points
here's my hope man
um
like I can't think of anything that
would bring me more joy than
y'all calling me in a few months and
being like hey come to our wedding in
San Diego that'd be awesome
and right below that and that's just
because I'm a romantic sucker right
below that
I can't think of anything that would
bring me more joy than two adults
looking at each other saying all right
we've been together five years and I
love you and I love you too
but just because we love each other
doesn't mean we're right for each other
forever and ever amen
and as painful and as gut-wrenching and
is heartbreaking and is is dark as it's
going to be
we're gonna spend some time apart and
see what that's like
either one of those paths is fine I
think the challenge is you all both have
to recognize that both of you get to
choose that path
how's that land on you
so Kyle you've heard me talk and talk
and talk and talk
um
do you have any more peace at the end of
this call it feels like you're headed
towards a more a little more security
and what you see down the road
yeah I mean
everything you said nothing would make
me happier than either one of those
either just the right one that's fair
let me say this you know there's there's
not a right or wrong one
there's one that we're going to choose
and for both of you marriage is this
every day of my life I wake up and I ask
myself how can I love her better and
every day I wake up and I decide I'm
gonna be great per a great person to be
married to
every day I wake up and decide I'm gonna
love her or I'm gonna love him
that's marriage it's not a feeling it's
not a dude if you don't do this then I'm
gonna do this that's not marriage
that's a transaction that's true that's
a transaction if you don't give me four
dollars I'm not giving you a burger
that's what you do at Burger King bro I
guess not marriage
right marriage is like how can I love
you today
yeah and you all are y'all aren't
anywhere close to that I don't I you
could get there by December but y'all
are just gonna have to make some pretty
grown-up decisions about how you'll
treat one another
and that may look like Kyle you smashing
your phone
they may look like you deleting all
social media apps
and not calling anybody and Aubry that
may look like you deciding to have
family meals at your house once a week
and become part of this thing because if
you marry Kyle his whole family comes
with him he's been pretty clear about
that you don't get Kyle without getting
the family
how's it going overwhelming eventually
it's just
time and time it's five years from a
Happy Father's Day you know like it's
fine
yeah it's five years it's five years
we're past that now five years
so here here's here's honestly like if
y'all could
um
I say be grown-ups be adults but I don't
mean that in an ugly way but I mean if
you all could almost with business like
um like a business like persona
set up a long three-hour breakfast
together
and
go out 10 years
and say we've been married we get
married in December and we will have
been married for nine and a half years
what would we want our life to look like
then
kids jobs where are we living
have we moved out of one of the most
expensive places on planet Earth or if
we decide to stay here because it's just
so beautiful
um
what do you want our life to look like
and then back it up what would we have
to do right now to make that happen and
then you'll have to ask yourselves am I
in on that
and Kyle you may have to look at her and
say I'm not in
I don't ever want to hurt you I love you
but I'm not in
and I'm gonna stop coming around
I'm going to leave the house
I'm gonna go find my own place I'm gonna
go find my own way
and Aubry you might say
I don't want a guy that is always
texting and flirting with other women on
social media and I don't want a guy that
has good goes on dates without me and I
don't want a guy that fill in the blank
fill in the blank
and I want you to have the courage and
strength to say
I love you Kyle but this is not for me
or I want you to both look at each other
across the table and say I'm in
I'm in
Kyle you're looking for some magic you
know fairy dust to come from the sky to
to give you the answer it's not going to
come and Aubry you're waiting for this
moment when all of the other things in
this picture are gonna get swept away so
it's just perfect and and happy happily
ever after it's not gonna happen you're
gonna have to be two adults who sit down
at a table and say are you in or are you
in
if you're not all the way in then you're
all the way out
and I will love you I'll always have a
spot for you in my heart
but we're gonna have to do the do the
right thing now
thank you all so much for being brave
and for for walking me through
um I would love it if you reached out
let me know let me know
it's a coin flip guys y'all choose
I'm grateful for you we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
whoa on that last one
whoa
I didn't expect that
I said
so are you out
he was like yep
oh man
hey man at least at least we're being
honest and we can we can work from a
place of honesty there as we wrap up
today's show
uh Kelly's decided to kick me while I'm
down
with my uh
bajillion dollar
hey Daddy can we go on vacation this
year no son hey Daddy can we have
ice cream no daughter but we have
electricity we have electricity
oh boy all right so uh the song of the
day is by the great Eddie Grant and the
song's called
Electric Avenue hope you feel good about
yourself Kelly
I do song goes
song goes like this
now in the street there's violence
and and a lots of work to be done no
place to hang out our washing and I
can't blame it all on the sun oh no
we're gonna rock down to Electric Avenue
it's gonna be so expensive and then
we'll take it higher not at my house you
won't because my power doesn't work
we're gonna rock it down to Atlanta
Electric Avenue and then we'll take it
higher
not super certain I know what that means
but I think they're gonna get
electrocuted and get high from it is
that what this means Eddie help us out
love you guys bye
foreign